poser une nouvelle question on vous
trouve l'info regardez ce beau petit
chalet avec la pandémie
bien des gens se sont mis à la recherche
d'un coin tranquille mais si votre
refuge date des années 60 ou 70 il est
possible que derrière ce décor rustique
se cache du câblage électrique en
aluminium ou plutôt qu en cuivre
certains assureurs ne voit pas de
problème avec le câblage en aluminium
mais d'autres considèrent que cela
augmente le risque d'incendié pourquoi
avec les années une succession de
propriétaires ont bricolé amoureusement
leur chalet et ils ont peut-être
installé les crues même des composantes
électriques sans délai fillon si elles
étaient d'homologuer pour l'aluminium
michel bonneau corporation des maîtres
électriciens du québec les gens
s'affolent y est à lui pris l'eau donc
certains assureurs exigent que maître
électricien vérifier que ce bout d'une
heure par exemple
soit homologué pour l'aluminium vous
venez de dénicher la cabane de vos rêves
posez la question aux vendeurs s'il
connaît cette information doit être
demandé aussi à votre inspecteurs de
vérifier passé